avec julie garnier oratrice nationale de
la france insoumise bonsoir julie
garnier avec nous également on dirait
que stéphane ravier sénateur du
rassemblement national des bouches du
rhône bonsoir stéphane ravier
merci à vous également des gens là sur
rt france première question pour vous
j'ai les garnier une réaction à cette
déclaration d'amour en tout cas
interprétée comme telle par les
journalistes au lendemain de
manifestations de milliers de personnes
contre cet article 24 de la loi sécurité
globale une déclaration d'amour c'est
absolument pas sérieux on n'a pas besoin
de déclarations d'amour on a besoin de
rationalité or aujourd'hui on voit que
la loi qui est proposée elle est grave
elle porte atteinte aux libertés
elle met en place un modèle de
surveillance généralisée et on voit bien
que les éléments de langage sont
complètement abusif
il n'y a aucune préservation de la
liberté de la presse il n'y a aucune
consécration du droit d'informer au
contraire on est même attaqué là dessus
par l'onu et par d'autres organisations
comme les droits de l'homme et c est ce
qu on voit surtout c'est qu'il ya un
gouvernement qui crée la confusion
c'est pas en disant en martelant à
l'assemblée nationale que ça empêchera
les appels au meurtre c'est pas vrai les
appels aux meurtres sont déjà interdits
par la loi
il faut qu'ils mettent par exemple les
moyens d'en pharos et ce n'est pas non
plus en affirmant qu'on pourra toujours
diffuser les images
il faut arrêter avec les mensonges les
mensonges c'est quand on n'a pas les
arguments et les paroles on sait très
bien qu'elles s'envolent mais les écrits
restent et on sait que cette loi est
mauvaise elle est mal écrite et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a bregeras en 2022 ouais
c'est ce qu'a dit effectivement jean luc
mélenchon s'il était élu il abrogerait
cette loi il dit que c'est une dérive
d'un régime autoritaire sous
surveillance généralisée stéphane ravier
un commentaire c'est peut-être peut-être
d'amour c'est une oeuvre de soumission
aux journalistes et aux journalistes
français qui l'ont d'ailleurs qui ont
d'ailleurs rejeté parce que c'était
évidemment pas pas sérieux du tout je
crois que qu'à sa mère avait dû écrire
une lettre et une lettre d' excuses
qu'il aurait dû écrire mais aux
policiers pour ne pas leur avoir donné
l'émoi
10 humains et matériels de les permettre
de travailler une lettre d' excuses aux
français en général qui à qui il a
laissé qui les a laissés dans une
insécurité galopante puisqu'il ya entre
11 et 12 millions de crimes et délits
commis chaque année dans notre pays
selon l'observatoire de la délinquance
les français qui subissent de plus en
plus un terrorisme islamiste donc 7 6 6
christophe castaner avait dû écrire une
lettre c'est celle là qu'il aurait dû
écrire mais pas une lettre de soumission
aux journalistes qui l'ont qui l'ont
d'ailleurs méprisés et quant à ce projet
de loi moi je je soutiens - la police je
sais dans quelles conditions elle
travaille elle est la proie de toutes là
la racaille des cités et elle doit être
protégée
elle doit être protégée parce que ces
hommes et ces femmes parce que dans ces
uniformes il ya des hommes et des femmes
des pères de famille des mères de
famille qui vient subissent la loi de la
haine des racailles qui vont jusqu'à
leur domicile au domicile des policiers
pour les traquer pour les agresser de
façon de plus en plus violente il faut
donc les protéger
on est loin de l'état totalitaire qui a
été évoquée ici il ya quelques minutes
les protéger des actes malveillants sauf
que là ce sont les journalistes
finalement qui vont être sanctionnés
julie garnier comment évidemment
protéger les policiers je pense que là
dessus tout le monde est d'accord
comment est ce que on aurait pu protéger
les policiers
justement de diffusion de leur image
avec intention malveillante sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment
je crois que tout le monde a besoin
d'être protégée il ya pas qu les
policiers tout le monde a le droit
d'être protégé et y compris les
journalistes je rappellerai quand même
que les journalistes depuis les
manifestations des filets jaunes compte
54 blessés dont 12 très grave
sans parler de toutes les intimidations
les gardes à vue qu'ils ont eu
vous savez ce sont vos confrères et vos
concerts vous savez à quel point il ya
une situation préoccupante aujourd'hui
sur la liberté d'informer la liberté de
la presse je rappellerai quand même qu
emmanuel macron depuis qu'il est au
pouvoir a fait passer plusieurs lois qui
déjà intenté à sa liberté de la presse
il faut encore rappeler qu'il a fait
passer le loi de secret d'état
r il a fait passer aussi il a convoqué
des journalistes pour certaines enquêtes
qu'ils avaient mené notamment sur
l'usagé des armes françaises dans la
guerre au yémen ou encore sur
l'implication d'un sous-officier je vous
rappellerai dans la sphère bénin
tout ça ce sont des sécurité dont il
faut pouvoir préserver et aujourd'hui ce
qu'on constate c'est que dès que le
gouvernement est en difficulté son
premier réflexe c'est quoi puis c'est de
revenir sur les libertés comme il a été
en difficulté sur les gilet jaune il est
revenu sur la liberté de manifester
quand il est en difficulté face à la
presse il attaque ses libertés l'a donc
à chaque fois il faut être conscient de
la dérive liberticide qui s'installe et
oui aujourd'hui malheureusement il y a
de plus en plus un autoritarisme qui se
répand et c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
être vigilant je pense pas qu'il faille
opposé la sécurité des uns contre la
sécurité des autres je pense que tout le
monde a le droit à la sécurité c'est un
droit fondamental
y compris pour les policiers et
effectivement il va falloir travailler
l'étude mais travailler là dessus c'est
aussi mettre des moyens dans la police
henry ne l'aimé pas nous nous demandons
à ce qu'il y ait une vraie formation
pour les policiers à ce qu'il y ait des
vrais recrutement n'est pas que pour la
police pour tous les services publics
également il nous faut des hôpitaux
il nous faut tout ce qu'il fait
république aujourd'hui et ce qui fait
république ce sont les services publics
voilà c'est tout je voudrais qu'on parle
de cette dérive liberticide
elle concerne aussi un homme dans un
autre registre évidemment l'art et les
restrictions sanitaires qui ont été
mises en place stéphane ravier vous avez
dit que les français ne sont pas prêts à
être désincarcéré vous considérez donc
les français sont en prison avec ce
confinement dont on attend un
assouplissement mme harvey oui c'est
exactement cette manière là dont peut-il
à nantes ils le vivent ce ce confinement
le premier confinement ils ont estimé
que face à cette épidémie nouvelles on
n'avait pas pu faire autrement que au
final confiner le pays mais sept mois
plus tard sept mois après c'est bien le
problème que le gouvernement d pris
aucune mesure sanitaire sérieuse qui
n'ait pris aucune mesure en amande
comment comme l'a fait par contre
l'italie qui a recruté près de 20000
personnel soignant dix mille médecins
des infirmiers des aides soignants
eh bien la france n'a rien fait de tout
ça et au final en bout de course puisque
rien n'est fait en amant et bien en aval
on reconnaît incarcère les français on
incarcère les victimes c'est un petit
peu comme l'insécurité en général plus
que plutôt que de s'attaquer aux
délinquants
eh bien ce sont les honnêtes gens qui
s'enferme chez eux derrière des grilles
derrière des caméras qui restreignent
leur liberté qui ne vont plus dans
certains quartiers qui ne sortent plus à
certaines heures eh bien c'est la même
chose dans cette insécurité sanitaire
plutôt que s'attaquer aux dérives kong
et le coronel virus et bien on enferme
les français voilà on l'est on leur prix
on les prive de leur liberté et y
compris celle de travailler parce que
les commerçants les artisans les
indépendants ne demande pas de
subventions ne demande pas d'elle ils
demandent de travailler de vivre des
fruits de leur travail est de permettre
à ce pays de se libérer entièrement
parce que je la firme c'est une
véritable privation de liberté c'est une
incarcération qui se produit depuis qui
s'abat sur le pays depuis plusieurs
semaines et il est temps que cela cesse
et si emmanuel macron prend la parole
mardi vous l'avez dit ce n'est pas pour
annoncer une désincarcération ont baissé
pour gagner du temps pour pour faire
croire aux français que ça va venir pour
essayer de les calmer parce qu'il sait
très bien que les français n'en peuvent
plus de cette situation injuste qui les
frappent le maniema croit un premier
plus de clarté il a promis de donner un
cap julie garnier vous y croyez je ne
sais pas ce que va décider manuel macron
puisque toute façon il décide tout seul
dans son coin et il ne rencontre la
personne donc il fait ils n'ont aucun
bilan n'est fait des actions jusque là
et c'est bien dommage parce que je pense
que dans ces moments là c'est là où nous
avons plus besoin de démocratie
or aujourd'hui c'est précisément à celle
ci qu'il s'attaque au delà de ça je
pense qu'effectivement notre première
arme face à ce qui nous arrive c'est
d'abord la solidarité monsieur parler
des des commerçants oui on a besoin de
solidarité mais pourquoi est ce que il
ne propose pas justement un fonds de
solidarité vis-à-vis de ces petits
commerçants
pourquoi est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on a d'un
côté des profiteurs de crise qui font
des milliards de bénéfices et qui me
rendent absolument pas compte et qui
n'aide pas justement à côté les petits
commerces pourquoi est ce qu'il n'ya pas
cette solidarité fiscale
aujourd'hui oui il faut s'attaquer au
bout dit qu'il faut s'attaquer aux
délinquants très bien mais pourquoi vous
parlez jamais d'évasion fiscale
aujourd'hui si nous n'avons pas les
moyens dans les hôpitaux sinon nous
n'avons pas les moyens dans la police
c'est bien parce qu'il ya de l'évasion
fiscale et que nous ne passent jamais à
la caisse pour pouvoir régler la note de
tout ce dont nous avons besoin de
services publics
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui que rec avec
l'évasion fiscale c'est 100 hôpitaux
qu'on pourrait financer 100 hôpitaux ni
plus ni moins donc moins bien que tout
ce dont on a besoin on se le fait
d'abord dilapidé par des puissants qui
ne rendent jamais de comptes et que les
manuels macron sert en premier
aujourd'hui la question est de faire
passer les 99% en premier et pas les 1%
réponse c'était fade ravier je vous ai
vu réaliser un oui oui mais écoutez mon
interlocutrice cela je ne peux pas lui
et je veux pas lui faire le reproche de
ne pas écouter chacune de mes
interventions mais cela fait longtemps
déjà que je dénonce non seulement la
fraude fiscale qui c'est qui s'élève à
peu près à 100 milliards d'euros par an
mais aussi la fraude sociale qui atteint
le sommet de 45 milliards d'euros et la
fraude migratoires dans madame et
monsieur mélenchon ne parle jamais au
contraire ils encouragent la fraude
migratoires qui dans notre pays coûte
aux contribuables des dizaines de
milliards d'euros
et je me promène on prononce depuis le
début de cette crise pour cette liberté
que l'on doit accorder au delà de la
solidarité bien sûr laquelle je souscris
mais ça n'a qu'un temps la solidarité ça
ne peut pas faire vivre les milliers les
millions de commerçants
donc il faut une liberté accordée aux
petits comme on les appelle aux petits
commerçants aux artisans aux
indépendants qui est accordée aux gros
qui est accordée aux gros c'est vrai il
n'y a pas de raison que les gros puisse
continuer à faire de gros bénéfices et
que nos petits commerces qui représente
aussi notre art de vivre de commercer à
la française est bien meurent chaque
jour un peu plus parce que au-delà de
l'âme de la mort économique
c'est un drame humain qui est en train
de se produire c'est le le diraient les
commerçants sont dedans
sont dans une situation dans une
situation telle que leur désespoir
pardonnez moi c'est le terme je
cherchais leur désespoir atteint celui
des agriculteurs et on sait que dans
notre pays
un agriculteur se suicident tous les
deux jours moi je ne veux pas que ce ce
chiffre soit le même
je souhaite d'abord évidemment que ça ne
soit plus le cas chez les agriculteurs
mais je ne veux plus qu'il faut que je
ne veux pas qu'ils frappent pardon des
commerçants les artisans car ils sont
abandonnés à eux aussi tant sur le plan
économique que sur le plan humain et
dans ce domaine là le pire est devant
nous ouais c'est vrai que les chiffres
indiquent un doublement des cas de
dépression julie garnier depuis le
premier confinement queen des fêtes de
fin d'année est ce qu'il faudrait c'est
ce qu'il faut selon vous desserrer
l'étau ou privilégier toujours l'anglais
les engorgements dans les hôpitaux
juste avant pour répondre quand même
j'aimerais que monsieur et de la
cohérence entre les discours et les
actes le seul problème avec le front
national fin avec l'extrême droite c'est
qu'à chaque fois ils font des discours
mais j'aimerais qu'il dise aux gens que
quand il fallait voter au parlement
européen justement pour protéger les
emplois sur place locaux et être contre
justement les pouces avait le fait de
délocaliser
emma ils ont voté contre dites-le ça
aussi or vous faites exactement
contraire de ce que vous votez dites le
aussi que à chaque fois là par exemple
quand il s'agit de revenir sur les
libertés pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
voté avec la république en marche
justement à nouveau sur cette loi qui
est liberticide et alors que là vous
défendez les libertés soyez cohérent
arrêtez de mentir à chaque fois aux gens
moi c'est ça que je trouve insupportable
dans la politique et est ce que je vois
aujourd'hui c'est que là vous me
demandez comment est-ce qu'il faut
réagir sur les fêtes
bien évidemment je souhaiterais que tout
le monde puisse profiter des fêtes avec
sa famille parce que c'est bien
évidemment un moment qui est privilégié
que tout le monde souhaite
si je vois qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
cette situation là c'est parce qu'il ya
eu des choix politiques qui ont été
faits avant ses choix politiques
il faut les dénoncer faut dire qu'il y
avait d'autres alternatives possibles
que quand on demande des services
publics quand on manifeste aux côtés des
soignants nous on y est
monsieur n'y est pas
donc j'arrête il faut bien qu'ils
arrêtent avec ses doubles discours parce
que c'est vraiment malhonnête vis-à-vis
des gens répondent stephen stanley si si
oui mes blessures que si je suis aux
côtés aux côtés des soignants je suis
aux côtés des commerçants j'y étais il
ya quelques jours devant la préfecture à
marseille aux côtés des commerçants
je n'ai pas vu de représentant de la
france est soumise
madame parler des choix politiques je
rappelle que la france est soumise à
appeler appelé à voter pour emmanuel
macron si emmanuel macron applique sa
politique antisociale ultralibéral chère
madame
c'est grâce à des gens comme vous qui
ont sans doute à voter pour lui il y a
quelques années et qui voterez à nouveau
pour lui si la situation était la même
en 2022 qu'en 2017
donc s'il ya eu un manque de manque de
cohérence en matière politique
elle est plutôt de votre côté parce que
nous sommes pour la préférence nationale
nous sommes aux poudres
la production locale pour les circuits
courts vous vous êtes pour une
immigration massive qui mais qui met en
concurrence nos travailleurs avec une
concurrence déloyale tend vers
l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur
pour revenir à la situation de fin
d'année la situation de fin d'année il
faut il faut que les commerçants
puissent travailler mais ils sont
sérieux les commerçants comme les bars
comment les resteront ils ont été les
premiers à appliquer et de façon très
stricte et les consignes sanitaires un
restaurant un bar un commerçant peut
très bien s'adapter c'est d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus facile de s'adapter dans
une petite rue structure que dans une
grande structure
c'est une question d'organisation et les
commerçants savent le faire il faudrait
que le que le gouvernement est bien
prennent
prennent connaissance de la réalité du
terrain plutôt que d'être enfermé dans
ses dans les ministères ou d'être
enfermé à l'elysée aulas a entendu là la
france la france réelle elle sait faire
on a entendu effectivement les
commerçants disent qu'il pouvait très
bien s'adapter
julie garnier vouliez réagir très
brièvement pour conclure ce débat
oui non juste dire que les mensonges ne
sont pas des arguments et que quand on
dit que les personnes nous par exemple
nous appelions à voleter emmanuel macron
second tour
c'est faux je pense qu'on a pris assez
justement claque là dessus parce que
justement nous n'accueillons pas à voter
pour
pour emmanuel macron me lapp l'ont pas
voté non plus pour marine le pen parce
que nous savons très bien que d'un côté
comme de l'autre c'est c'est tout
simplement les mêmes c'est exactement
des deux faces d'une même pièce et c'est
bien ça que nous et que nous contestons
ne vous en déplaise et nous avons un
autre projet à présenter aux français et
auquel certains autres s'il faut parler
et on découvrira effectivement puisque
jean luc mélenchon s'est déclaré lui
aussi candidat à l'instar de marine le
pen avec nous ses séjours présidentiels
de 2022 merci beaucoup en tout cas à
tous les deux d'avoir participé ce soir
à ce débat en direct